[Musique]
la vanne on a beau chercher son visage
dans les rues
on le voit pas
même s'il a quitté le pouvoir son nom
est dans tous les esprits
sa vision ses idées règne encore sur
l'île
bah
lui c'est fidel castro l'homme fort de
cuba pendant plus de 50 ans
[Musique]
mais on cherche en vain son portrait sur
les murs et si on ne trouve pas c'est
qu'il a interdit tout culte de la
personnalité
je
[Musique]
c'est derrière les murs de cette maison
que se retrouvent les meilleures images
du dirigeant cubain
je contacte pour la première fois trois
grands photographes de fidel castro se
réunissent pour échanger sur l'image du
commandante trois générations pour
parler de lui comme ils ne l'ont jamais
fait auparavant
quand il se met à réfléchir
il joue sm est comme ça voici le
pionnier roberto salaces ces photos ont
fait le tour du monde que j'aime le plus
c'est une photo que j'ai fait dans des
conditions très difficiles
c'était la première fois que je voyais
fidèles n'est pas un homme facile à
photographier poker ce qu'il fait
beaucoup de gestes cela parle avec les
mains et il fait souvent des grimaces
aux saveurs et les concerts
[Musique]
il a sept personnalités quels que soient
son allure il paraît bien ce n'est pas
seulement le sujet ni le physique mais
sa personnalité
ce qu'il dégage fait web 98
photographier fidel c'est comme une fête
parce qu'il est impétueux il parle
toujours
on doit chercher le meilleur angle et se
demander si on a une photo marc quant à
l'allemagne elle pas facile de connaître
l'homme derrière le commandant castro
celui qu'on considère comme un dictateur
ou bien un héros
on
derniers monstres sacrés de la politique
du xxème siècle il s'est confronté à dix
présidents américains
l'homme au discours fleuve qui a survécu
à plus de 600 attentes qu'on l'ait mme
ou le haïssent il ne laisse personne
indifférent il n'est pas un dirigeant
comme les autres les gens se font une
idée précise de ce que devrait être un
chef d'état fidèle n'a rien à voir avec
ça rares sont les leaders mondiaux qui
ont suscité autant de haine
à cause d'un régime politique et
économique rigide communiste et
l'exportation de sa révolution en
amérique latine et en afrique
je pense que finel et le conspirateur le
plus brillant le plus fantastique que le
monde ait connu par quel pays du monde
rares aussi sont les dirigeants qui ont
suscité autant d'enthousiasmé
d'admiration
il a apporté l'éducation et la santé aux
cubains il a exporté ses médecins à cuba
comme à l'étranger il est perçu par
beaucoup comme un symbole de résistance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attaquer fidesz et attaquer la
révolution et même si nous l'aimons on
ne peut pas dire qu'il soit sans défaut
mais ça nous blesse qu'on les utilise
pour nous faire du mal par allart primal
roberto chill est conscient que le sujet
est délicat
il n'est pas seulement photographe il a
surtout été le caméraman personnel de
fidel castro durant 25 ans je pensais
que mes yeux étaient les yeux du monde
il n'y avait qu'une seule caméra et
c'était la mienne des centaines d'heures
de tournage des milliers de kilomètres
parcourus un accès unique
cela m'a donné l'occasion de connaître
fidèles le leader les mythes
révolutionnaires connu mondialement
je vous propose de découvrir un autre
fidèle plus humain le proche des gens
fidèles plus intime que peu de gens ont
eu la chance de rencontrer je vous
invite donc à prendre la caméra micro
éclairage
allons rencontrer ses amis et ses
proches ceux qui peuvent parler de
l'être humain du fidèle plus intime et
c'est aussi un homme comme vous un être
humain mortel comme vous et moi
[Musique]
roberto chill et nous amène découvrir
l'oeuvre del castro qui connaît pour la
première fois à la caméra des proches
ont accepté de parler du fidel castro
que l'on connaît moins ceux qui vont
parler de l'homme sont des amis des
parents des proches
ce sont des gens qui l'aiment et la dnif
ils ne font pour la mémoire
pour l'histoire comme l'a fait gabriel
garcia marquez c'est le fidel castro que
je crois connaître un homme aux
habitudes austère aux illusions
insatiable d'une éducation formelle à
l'ancienne aux paroles mesurées et au
manière nuancée et incapables de
concevoir une idée qui ne soit pas
colossal
[Musique]
pour les fidèles
on peut l'aimer ou là y aller mais on ne
peut pas rester indifférent
tout le monde ici l'appel chill et
[Musique]
s'inquiète pour dresser un portrait de
l'homme derrière le commandant commence
avec mariela castro la nièce de fidel et
la fille de raul castro
on a souvent utilisé l'image de don
quichotte pour parler des rêveurs de
l'impossible et fidèle a été un de ces
rêveurs il a démontré plusieurs fois que
des utopies peuvent devenir réalité
winga match à la réalité alors dans ce
sens il a un côté donquichottesque nous
intéresser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
don quichotte
l'hidalgo fou de miguel de cervantes est
souvent associée en amérique latine à
des libérateurs comme simon bolivar où
josé marti fidèles est un descendant
d'espagnol et son père venait de la
province de galice katiuska blanco et la
biographe personnel de fidel castro des
galiciens il a hérité de l'honorabilité
du caractère noble et chevaleresque et
assez longtemps mais d'une culture de
résistance et d'une capacité à vaincre
les difficultés
fidel est né dans le petit village de
birane en 1926 dans une famille aisée de
cultivateurs de canne à sucre
il est envoyé en pension dans les
meilleurs collèges religieux selon ses
professeurs et se démarque comme bon
élève sportif et lieder il étudie à
l'université pour devenir avocat human
zoo paix entre sony en résumé de son
village la façonner l
il lui a donné les coutumes le respect
et la sensibilité envers les êtres
humains même les plus démunis et et
l'école lui a donné la formation et le
développement de l'intelligence la
capacité de réflexion et de méditation
si le serviront bien toute sa vie l'om
mais ce lien taille importante à une
souris un homme réfléchi qui va poser un
geste insensé défié la dictature de
foule renshaw batista et sa puissante
armée cuba est une île riche mais ces
paysans vivent dans la misère la havane
est un repère de la mafia américaine
le régime est corrompu et ils répriment
cruellement ce qui demande des réformes
notamment des groupes d'étudiants des
révoltes éclatent en 1953 castro et une
poignée de jeunes révolutionnaires
tentent de s'emparer de la caserne de
moncada à santiago de cuba
si les connaît un témoin privilégié de
l'époque martin alors race elle a
commencé sa carrière de journaliste en
couvrant l'événement il faut avoir un
très grand idéalisme pour s'attaquer à
une armée aussi puissante que celle de
batista
[Musique]
l'assaut de la moncada est un échec
castro est arrêté
au procès marthaler as pensé voir un
homme vaincu des faits elle découvre au
contraire un jeune avocat qui se défend
lui-même avec fougue
selon moi ce fut la première victoire
après il ya eu l'histoire matsu draps ça
illustre bien comment il est parvenu à
se transformer et accusé en accusateurs
c'est là qu'il prononce cette fameuse
phrase condamnez moi cela n'a aucune
importance l'histoire mme absoudra
premiers traits de caractère de l'homme
il maîtrise le pouvoir des mots
condamné à 15 ans de prison batista va
l'amnistié deux ans après pour ne pas en
faire un martyr
nous sommes en 1955 castro s'exile alors
au mexique où ils complotent à nouveau
pour renverser le dictateur cubain
l'année suivante il achète un vieux
bateau le g et débarque à cuba ils sont
seulement 82 ans d'abord ils sont
dénoncés c'est encore un échec
seuls douze hommes parviendront à
s'échapper dans la sierra maestra dont
son frère raul et le jeune médecin
argentin che guevara
des années plus tard fidel castro avoue
qu'il aurait pu faire les choses
autrement
à propos de l'expédition du grain mahé
de l'assaut de la moncada
il m'a dit si on avait pu ni l'un ni
l'autre n'auraient été nécessaire on
aurait dû aller directement à la sierra
maestra cr idate guillermon garcia frias
un paysan devenu commandant de la
révolution
il a été parmi les premiers à rejoindre
cette poignée de guérilleros dans la
montagne cinq fusils fidèles en avait
200 faisait ça
fidel m'a dit maintenant on l'a gagné la
guerre voilà le genre d'homme les deux
stratèges qu'il ait la guerre civile a
succédé à de violentes émeutes dans
toutes les parties de l'île de cuba à la
suite de plusieurs revers les rebelles
de fidel castro se sont retranchés dans
les forêts de la province d'orient
ainsi débute l'épopée la sierra maestra
avec trois fois rien la légende prend
forme
une aventure qui va durer plus de deux
ans ailleurs les qualités you will ohman
living and despite wiiware on lit tout
et même nom oui à tout moment d'être
belfort baby star is not mad men et
vérité se voir document de radio-canada
a été tourné en 1958 par le reporter de
la bbc eric douche mid
ils montrent un fidel castro sûr de lui
[Musique]
un grand pouvoir psychologique s'il
n'arrive pas à convaincre personne et le
convaincre c'est sa conviction qui nous
atteler rejoindre moi il m'a convaincu
j'étais prêt à offrir ma vie si
nécessaire ce n'était pas de questions
futiles
c'est un problème difficile
[Musique]
ne va pas laisser à ses compères disait
toujours si tu veux convaincre le peuple
de cuba
tu dois convaincre fidèles car il a la
capacité de convaincre le pays et le
monde entier il a une grande force de
persuasion le pouvoir de convaincre
ils l'utilisent auprès des médias
étrangers pour faire accepter sa
révolution communiste
non du moins pas encore che guevara lui
ne s'est jamais caché de l'être le che
devient commandant de la révolution il
restera aussi l'un des meilleurs amis de
castro à l'eid à la fille du che ouvre
pour chill et son album de famille est
là en vrai mon père était un homme très
cultivé
ils étaient très compétents ils
pouvaient être l'égal de fidèles mais il
a reconnu fidèles comme son guide
elle récompense fut elle commet sourire
les barbus victorieux entre à la havane
grâce à l'appui populaire la guérilla
écrasé l'armée de batista
le rêve est devenu réalité
fidel castro triomphale il voulait faire
quelque chose il le faisait coûte que
coûte contre vents et marées ne
s'arrêtait jamais tant qu'il n'était pas
parvenu à l'obtenir et sa ville à
prouver comme une fois dans l'histoire
il a réalisé des choses impossibles il
s'obstinait jusqu'à la réussite un vrai
galicien trois espagnols très capricieux
impulsif obstiné de nouveau très
révélateur hecquet nancy a fait il est
né comme ça c'est un homme qui a eu la
possibilité de transformer ses rêves en
réalité être réalisation soit aignan il
y a plus de gens qui ont la chance de
dire ça précédemment
la révolution cubaine suscite beaucoup
de sympathie dans le monde
fidel castro fait une tournée
nord-américaine pour expliquer sa
position
le voici à montréal en 1959 capitalisme
ou communisme il faut choisir le monde
est polarisée très vite castro satire
l'hostilité de washington en
nationalisant les terres de compagnies
américaines pour sa réforme agraire
washington impose les premières
sanctions commerciales et cuba se
rapproche de plus en plus de moscou
d'avoir obtenu le résultat qu'il
recherchait comme le proclamaient les
banderoles attaché aux camions à nantes
à la havane des campesinos cuba et
patois fidèles elle est entre tes mains
et maintenant on peut se demander ce que
va faire castro
[Musique]
c'est la guerre froide
durant 50 ans fidel castro exercera
fermement le pouvoir d'un état
communiste
[Musique]
la folie de don quichotte et la folie
des révolutionnaires sont similaires
je suis sûr que don quichotte n'aurait
pas hésité à faire face aux géants du
nord
la petite ville de berck où carla deux
heures de la havane
[Musique]
schyle et le caméraman se consacre
maintenant à la photographie il expose
sa vision artistique sur le personnage
historique
photos vidéos sculptures cette
exposition hommage s'intitule fidèles et
fidèle c'est l'expression de raul castro
pour dire que son frère est tout
simplement irremplaçable
sur cette photo on envoie un leader un
révolutionnaire
l'homme qui est incapable de battre une
armée dans la sierra maestra et
surmonter la crise des missiles
la crise des missiles a tenu le monde en
haleine au bord d'une troisième guerre
mondiale nucléaire elle était précédée
d'une escalade de tensions entre cuba et
les etats unis en 1961 les américains
échouent dans leurs tentatives d'
envahir cuba par la baie des cochons
les états unis interdisent alors tout
commerce avec lille les dizaines de
navires de guerre des centaines d'avions
prennent part à ce blocus de fait les
sous-marins patrouille au large des
côtes cubaines prêt à intercepter tout
cas pro 1962 des ogives nucléaires
soviétiques sont en territoire cubain et
vise les états unis de john kennedy
comment moi américain est prêt à envahir
cuba pour détruire les bases de fusées à
la vente c'est la fièvre castro et
lectrices son peuple ils refusent tout
démantèlement des bases de fusée la
crise devient une partie de poker entre
les deux superpuissances
fidel castro attise la foule
il se dit prêt au sacrifice ultime je
les vis dans des moments très difficiles
à la grèce des missiles j'ai pu observer
sa patience car sa tranquillité absolue
en soute pour lequel parce qu'il savait
ce qu'il allait faire
ils avaient plus ou moins calculé mon
cas et il savait comment jouer aux
échecs ses pions étaient placés ce qu'il
allait faire
tranquillité absolue
pourtant cette tranquillité absolue peut
virer brusquement à la colère comme en
témoigne martin lauras première chose
qu'il fait quand il se fâche c'est ça
regardez nos salles
un soap as we live au puy il fait des
pas très long des grands pas encore et
encore
et ensuite il s'arrête ce soit et ce
qu'alice selena moscou fini par
s'entendre avec washington plus de
missiles mais pas d'invasion américaine
de cuba non plus l'entente a été perçu
comme une trahison par fidel castro
il en profitera pour obtenir des
concessions de moscou du pétrole russe
pas cher est un débouché pour la canne à
sucre cubaine fidel est un homme qui
surprend toujours
à chaque conflit avec les etats-unis
dans chaque situation difficile il avait
un talent pour renverser la situation
bilal l'adopter il renvoyait la balle
dans leur camp et ils sont amusés comme
si c'était le meilleur match de
base-ball ou une partie d'échecs au
début des années 60 l'aide économique
soviétique et généreuse les cubains sont
remplis d'espoir à cuba de socialisme
avance au rythme du cha-cha-cha ni
communisme ni capitalisme disait fidel
castro pendant la révolution c'est fini
cuba a choisi son camp
pouey live à toi attaquant de toulouse
[Musique]
ricardo alarcon a été un proche
collaborateur de fidel castro pendant
des amis quatre lots fidèle à un seul
défaut un grand défaut il ne fait jamais
les choses à moitié
un média quand il fait quelque chose il
le fait de la conception à la fin apple
finale et or avec une passion et une
intensité unique commun cela il compte
parmi ses amis de nombreuses
personnalités politiques
le canadien pierre elliott trudeau un
grand intellectuel comme lui ces images
proviennent des archives personnelles de
fidel castro
trudeau est le premier leader occidental
à faire une visite officielle à cuba en
1976 durant l'embargo américain
[Musique]
en 2000 il s'est même déplacé à montréal
pour les funérailles de son ami pierre
trudeau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autre ami le sud africain nelson mandela
qui l'a soutenu dans sa lutte contre
l'apartheid mais celui qu'il a aimé le
plus haut point de se livrer avec lui
hier des jeux d'enfance et hugo chavez
l'ancien président vénézuélien qu'il
considérait comme un fils
[Musique]
franck fernandez est un compositeur
interprète de renommée internationale il
est un autre ami intime de fidel castro
fidel n'est pas un dirigeante
c'est un artiste un génie de la parole
de la palabre un journaliste lui a
demandé un jour quelles seraient les
conditions pour devenir votre ami
il attendait une réponse politisé
idéologique intellectuelle des cours
sont violents et il a répondu lors la
condition sinequanone pour être mon ami
c'est d'être une personne
d'après le pianiste castres on peut être
féroce comme un lion ou tendres comme un
enfant il est perfectionniste un patient
et exigent la fidl ne pardonne pas la
déloyauté ni la lâcheté et encore moins
la lâcheté politique politique perd mais
c'est un homme avec qui on peut discuter
argumenter et le contredire côtés à
condition que ce ne soit pas pour
dénaturer ses idées ni pour aller à
l'encontre des principes de la
révolution
on le sait
politiquement fidel castro ne tolère pas
d'opposition
on lui reproche les procès sommaire et
les exécutions les détention des
opposants et l'absence de liberté
d'expression
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est vrai et l'entraîneur les à la
façade dans une entrevue exclusive à
radio canada en 2000 fidel castro parle
pour la première fois de l'existence de
prisonniers politiques
non mais récemment elle prit ainsi que
la révolution était libre organise aux
organisatrices et organisationnelles
contribution ypérite ya mais le
commanditaire et nous aurions apprécié
comme sonné pour que nous sommes presque
mon nom lié aux pressions politiques
pour raison de blessure contre
révolutionnaires criminelle
c'est comme ça notre peuple est victime
d'agressions sommes en guerre nous
souffrons d'un blocus criminel le dire
c'est facile mais le vivre c'est autre
chose
si le père au bingo
l'homme doit vivre avec les décisions
difficiles controversée du commandant
pas toujours évident selon sa nièce
fidèle à une formation catholique
jésuites
imaginez comme c'est difficile pour un
homme de formation chrétienne et
humaniste de prendre des décisions
radicales
c'était très difficile thomas des
cessionnaires l'attaquant est la moindre
risée des décisions qui lui ont valu
beaucoup d'ennemis toute sa vie fidèle
caston pour la défier le destin frôlé la
mort il a échappé à 638 tentative
d'assassinât selon le livre des records
guinness qui se base sur des documents
de la cia y est élevée une fontaine
garde du corps personnel de fidel castro
et boukari sur laquelle il y a eu
plusieurs tentatives de meurtre qui
n'ont pas réussi cela est dû à
l'efficacité des services de sécurité
son goût des bonnes foules et de
l'improvisation avait de quoi donner des
sueurs froides à son service de sécurité
malgré les menaces
il se vantait de ne pas porter de gilet
pare balles au chili un individu a caché
un pistolet à l'intérieur d'une caméra
comme la vôtre pour tirer sur un
en 1990 c'est l'effondrement du bloc
soviétique
ajoutez à l'embargo américain l'économie
de l'île est dévasté cuba est isolé des
milliers de cubains s'enfuit vers la
floride pour des raisons politiques et
économiques
on l'appelait la crise des balseros
minant des embarcations de fortune
fabriqué avec des chambres r
[Applaudissements]
le plus connu de ces bals 0 s'appelle
elian gonzalez cet enfant de 6 ans
naufragés de la mer une partie de sa
famille voulait qu'il reste aux états
unis mais son père le réclamaient à cuba
fidel castro en a fait sa cause
[Applaudissements]
en juin 2000 le petit elian gonzalez
revient au pays en héros
[Musique]
nous allons rencontrer elian gonzalez
il est très connu à cuba et même dans le
monde
quinze ans plus tard qu'il et retourne
chez les gones thales pour rencontrer
l'enfant devenu ingénieur aux états unis
on me parlait de fidèles en mal fidel
était le diable
c'était un ogre il mauvaise personne qui
tuaient des gens et six mois après son
retour
fidel castro va le rencontrer pour la
première fois ci que tout j'ai été
rassurée quand il m'a fait rire en me
donnant une boîte de bonbons et le livre
l'âge d'or alors j'ai vu une personne
qui faisait des blagues et plaisanter
avec un enfant mais ne pouvait être ni
un ogre ni un assassin car ce final
c'est beau le poma ensuite on a
développé une complicité fouet et à
[Musique]
castro est devenu une sorte de grand
père pour éliane et sa famille il a
partagé avec eux des repas et des
discussions pendant des heures voire des
nuits entières tire un enseignement de
tout ce qu'il ne sait pas il invente ou
il change de sujet pour ne pas être
désavantagés si elle est par exemple si
tu lui parles de base-ball ou si tu lui
poses une question à laquelle il ne peut
pas répondre
il essaie de composer une autre plus
compliqué ou bien il change de sujet en
sachant qu'il ne connaîtra pas à akbou
et a démarré comme ça il se retrouve
toujours au dessus
curieux passionné il est tout ce qui lui
tombe sous la main des patients y en a
plusieurs
l'agriculture développement de vaccins
la formation de médecins
il peut y consacrer un temps infini
négligé de se nourrir en perdre le
sommeil
[Musique]
eusebio les halles et l'historien en
charge de la restauration de la havane
pour khalifa les secrets contrairement à
la croyance populaire cet homme des
longs discours a une grande capacité
d'écouté et de réflexion
une immense soif de connaissances dans
qu'elle n'arrive pas à comprendre un
problème il peut sans cesse posé des
questions à celui qui voudrait
s'aventurer à discuter avec lui je
recommanderais de se préparer sinon on
court le risque de se faire plumer comme
un petit poulet non des et de rester
sans voix
berne d'halloween capas des faits
pareils tous ses proches s'accordent sur
un point l'homme n'aime pas perdre
dans la rue les gens disent fidesz
n'aime pas perdre même dans un concours
de crachats vous savez les enfants qui
jouent à celui qui va cracher le plus
loin oui oui c'est très mauvais perdant
c'est vrai il ne peut pas perdre ce
n'est pas qu'ils trichent mais c'est
qu'il n'aime pas échouer alors ils
trouvent toujours le moyen de gagner
[Musique]
l'exemple le plus fameux de ce besoin de
victoires a été le match de baseball
entre fidel castro et son ami hugo
chavez le président du venezuela
c'était incroyable les gardes du corps
de chavez jouait contre cette fidèle et
des personnes plus âgées
andré a fait une belle et quand fidel a
vu qu'il perdait il a triché mais pour
rire boucau lors les aventures il est
allé chercher les meilleurs joueurs de
baseball de cuba et les à déguiser avec
des moustaches et des cheveux blancs
[Applaudissements]
finalement tu avais si rendu compte que
c'était une farce fidèles l'avait
trompée c'est un peu comme ça qu'il est
[Applaudissements]
intelligent persévérant passionné qui
aime gagner pour les uns
on était excessif mauvais perdant pour
les autres
[Musique]
le studio privé de franck fernandez
schyle et lui a demandé ce que fidèle
évoqué pour lui le grand pianiste
improvise
[Musique]
fidel est protégé sa vie privée car
c'est un homme qui veut et je crois que
c'est bien préserver le plus possible ce
que vous voulez savoir dans ce
documentaire nous sommes très peu
nombreux à pouvoir en parler avec lui
et parmi les secrets les mieux gardés de
l'homme qui suscite aussi toutes les
curiosités ses relations avec les femmes
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que fidel
est un homme profondément amoureux et
affectueux il ne peut pas vivre sans
amour et surtout sans celui des êtres
humains
un journaliste malte alors à ce qu'il a
connu au début de la révolution se
souvient d'un charmeur éloquent yokas il
ya des maires je crois que oui et plus
encore c'était un séducteur il était
jeune
séduisant et attirant mais cela n'était
pas seulement dû à sa genèse il était
aussi délicat tripoli et élégant avec
les femmes en général
innover ce n'est pas à moi d'en parler
mais fidèle est connue pour ses belles
paroles sa manière de parler il faudrait
demander à ces airs qui ont été ses
maîtresses ou ses compagnes panier il
est célèbre pour sa façon de conquérir
mannequinat
[Musique]
fidel est un homme romantique
d'après les femmes qu'il a aimées êtes
un homme très sentimental tendre
spéciale très séducteur - persian
certaines de ces femmes ont révélé
qu'elles ont été aimée avec passion
[Musique]
il se marie une première fois en 1948
avec mirta diaz balart ensemble ils ont
eu un fils fidelito sept ans plus tard
ils se séparent
sa vie privée commence à prendre
l'alluré d'un mythe combien at il eu
d'enfant ce sont des histoires privées
mais effectivement il a beaucoup
d'enfants et la plupart avec sa femme
d'aliens actuelle compagne est là mais
il en a trop pour don fidélité au fils
de sa première épouse
c'est une belle histoire d'amour et on
est aux liens qu'on devrait raconter un
jour fait qu'il y va c'est ce qui arrive
quand les hommes sont 10 ans est remonté
charismatique et mappy com huit enfants
donc ta famille de fidel castro a
pratiquement été un secret d'état
il a connu dalia soto del valle dans les
années 60 elle et sa compagne depuis
1981 mais les cubains ne l'ont
découverte que récemment
ensemble ils ont eu cinq fils
rappelez-vous ce photographe qui a pris
ces clichés si intime
alex c'est en fait le fils de fidel
castro
ma mère ils lui ont toujours été
ensemble et il s'est toujours préoccupé
d'elle c'est la première fois que son
fils acceptent de parler de la vie de
famille la maison et la famille était
comme un sanctuaire
n'écoutez jamais les informations la
presse n'y aurait pas ce qu'il faisait
en famille restée très privé c'était le
sanctuaire où il venait se reposer
quel genre de père at il été ce bourreau
de travail qui courait après le temps et
de moyens ou pas ils s'inquiétaient de
nous même s'il était très occupé des
fois il passait les fins de semaine avec
nous même quand on joue au baseball près
de la maison
il venait jouer avec nous
il est effectué et les hommes il est
concentré sur la discussion il n'est pas
distant tu te sens très proche en
parlant avec lui les repas de famille à
la maison sont très importants c'est là
qu'on parle des bonnes et des mauvaises
choses
tous les soucis de la famille sont
abordés
une autre histoire d'amour paternel ou
inconnues et la relation entre fidel
castro et la fille du che
il y à de belles photos de moi dans les
bras de mon père et on voit que je veux
aller dans ceux de fidèles c'est à dire
ils sont là tous les deux moi je suis au
milieu et je penche du côté des fidèles
à m
pour aller d'un fidèle il n'est pas le
commandant en chef il est tout
simplement son trio son ton temps et la
feria paterna casser la figure
paternelle que j'ai toujours eu depuis
tout petit ton temps a toujours été
présent dans les moments les plus beaux
et les plus tristes aussi de ma vie
elle a pratiquement été adopté par fidel
castro à la mort de son père j'avais 4
ans et demi quand mon père est parti au
congo je n'ai jamais revu alors j'y suis
de situer cette image paternelle avec
celle de fidèles ce fut une relation
très belle oui plein de tendresse
d'ennahda d'affection fidel castro est
volontaire et disciplinés il a même
cessé de fumer le cigare symbole
national cubain pour lancer une campagne
anti tabac pour ses proches pas de
facilités pas de privilèges non plus n'a
pas été rose dans notre éducation
tout n'a pas été simple nous partions à
l'école primaire un auto mais il voulait
qu'on marche une bonne partie il nous
apprenait que tout n'était pas facile il
disait tout le monde ne va pas à l'école
en auto leurs parents n'ont pas les
moyens
vous devez apprendre ces réalités les
bonnes et les mauvaises
je m'en souviens encore nous devions
marché au moins deux ou trois kilomètres
voici des images qui n'ont jamais été
diffusés fidel castro à une fête
il était le témoin de mariage d'un ami
il se charge de préparer la paille elle
aime cuisiner et ça ne date pas d'hier
les amis italiens en visite
il donne sa recette personnelle de plats
de quand elle a répondu il était très
curieux très gourmands de tous dans la
vie pour améliorer ses connaissances il
allait chercher des recettes avec des
produits les plus nutritifs ou plus
savoureux et omar sy car ils échangent
et même des recettes avec ma mère entre
amis ou en famille fidel castro aime
aussi la plaisanterie autorise adoré
dans sa cabane il a un bon sens de
l'humour
il est très drôle je me souviens d'une
rencontre de famille on était tous là
mes oncles et les enfants et les petits
enfants ils ont commencé à raconter des
histoires fidèles étaient morts de rire
mon père faisait des blagues sur le g à
les combats et fidèle le disait en riant
et c'est aujourd'hui tu me le dis
un homme qui rit qui pleure aussi mes
rares ont été ceux qui en ont été
témoins
c'était à la mort de gaulle chavez son
fils politique et à celle de la
révolutionnaire scellèrent sanchez
considéré comme l'un de ses grands amis
de l'ong caritas est morte cette douleur
était telle que cela m'a rendu malade et
c'est vieil homme enfermé
j'étais là et ils passent à côté de moi
sans me voir il me permet passant par
l'art gilbert mais il ne voyait rien
il devait survivre continue il y avait
une douleur immense chez cet homme c'est
un être qui a une grande capacité
d'aimer quant à hélène qu'à passer à
part ammar
[Musique]
amoureux paternaliste et jovial voilà
comment il est décrit dans l'intimité
par ses proches
d'êtres humains ou le verrez aussi quand
il a quitté le pouvoir en le voyant
accablé par le poids de temps de
destiner je lui demandais ce qu'il
aimerait le plus faire en ce monde et il
me répondit immédiatement resté dans un
coin
[Musique]
salon du livre de la havane
si les signes son livre de photos
d'exposition se son témoignage est aussi
un hommage destiné au grand public
nous avons tous contribué à vous montrer
le portrait de fidèles mais le vrai
portrait c'est le temps qui va le
sculpter et l'ademe
tu as la victime
[Applaudissements]
le temps a passé c'est l'heure des
bilans et des biographies fidel castro
avoue lui-même qu'il aurait pu faire les
choses autrement
est elle fidèle et un être humain ce
n'est pas un dieu il a lui même reconnu
avoir commis des erreurs
une fois il a dit la plus grande que
nous ayons commise au moment du triomphe
de la révolution était de penser que
l'union soviétique savez construire le
socialisme
il a dit nous les révolutionnaires avons
commis des erreurs et on va commettre
d'autres mais on ne pourra jamais nous
reprocher de ne pas avoir été fidèle à
nos principes
fidel castro est resté plus de 50 ans la
tête de cuba
mais pour la première fois des proches
affirment qu'il a été tenté de quitter
le pouvoir
oui il a fait il faire juste après la
révolution quand il a accepté d'être
seulement premier ministre il s'est
retiré mais le peuple est descendu dans
la rue et l'a réclamé au pouvoir c'est
notamment j'ai pu le voir à différentes
occasions dans les discussions que nous
avons eues qui file à sévère dont il
était question de ce qu'il voulait faire
mais qu'il ne pouvait pas fait une
affaire d'état
dans l'autre il était trop engagé envers
le peuple et en compromis sont moins
grandes que la qualité est l'ombre
compris lors de cet homme accomplit une
mission un devoir comme la charge de
missionnaires religieux et ombres comme
aux fidèles des hommes comme fidèle dans
le fond sont des victimes qui souffrent
de l'accomplissement d'un devoir
des compliments tonnes d'e mail leur
rôle dans l'histoire les a empêchés
d'avoir une vie normale
plus tranquille tranquille par ramis et
ernie els travail rokia où nous avons
place elle sinon délais aucun sacrifice
[Applaudissements]
en 2006 quand il quitte ses fonctions
c'est son frère raul qui prend le
pouvoir depuis leur enfance comme frère
aîné fidel s'est sentie responsable de
raul et même aujourd'hui je crois qu'il
se considère un peu comme son protecteur
pour mon protecteur
mon père a dû s'imposer participer au
même titre que les autres
il n'aimait pas être le petit frère
protéger pour certains les castro fond
d'une dynastie pour d'autres raul a fait
ses preuves et a gagné sa place c'est
raoul le grand stratège qui dirige
maintenant le p
car en ce moment nous sommes en train de
rétablir des relations avec les
etats-unis une étape complexe et
difficile
quels moments très difficiles
fidèle analyse mais le dire histoire
c'est raul qui est haut comme en bas où
l'a dit une fois une chose importante
qui consulteraient toujours fidèle alors
je le croisais appart etc et les terres
il est alerte et il suit les événements
il ne peut pas prendre du recul se
distancer des problèmes importants du
pays
c'est paraît important de ne pas aider
tes boules
on dit que les grands hommes à la fin de
leur vie sont solitaires
est ce le cas de fidel castro d'une
certaine manière je crois que bien qu'il
soit accompagné par des centaines de
milliers de personnes qu'ils aiment
fidel est une personne de profonde
solitude des wc sont bons
il est temps que ce départ avait fait le
travail du temps et de la vie apparaît
souriant sial on voit un vieil homme
noble dont la tête et le coeur son
prisonnier d'un corps endommagés il a
une télé initia des ou cuerpo belle idée
prédomine p o live est prêt à laisser
filer ne le savais pas après tant
d'années de service on travaille auprès
du commandant allait prendre fin en 2006
le moment le plus douloureux
caldea qu'a été lorsqu'un jour on m'a
appelé pour filmer quelque chose
d'inattendu chill et son cameraman
personnel film la démission du
commandant personne ou presque ne
connaît l'existence de ces images secret
d'état elles sont diffusées ici pour la
première fois
[Musique]
philippe bach april may avec l'algérie
porsia ses fans la gamme
il est à dolly malade il a pris le
document officiel et il m'a demandé de
filmer au moment de signer pour que s'il
mourait on sache que le document était
véridique et non une falsification des
sceaux s'est ensuite laissé dresser
devant moi j'avais la caméra à l'épaule
et il m'a dit à la pause j'ai payé et
celui lui ai répondu
vive fidel et ses yeux se sont
embrouillées de la scène en panne
[Musique]
quand tu vois son corps vieillir
tu te rends compte que tu es devant un
être humain et pas devant un mythe
inaccessible c'est un homme en chair et
en os un vrais êtres humains
le
fidel castro un être humain qui a changé
la vie de millions de gens dictateur ou
sauveur personne ne peut nier qu'il a
déjà laissé sa marque dans le temps
la vanne on a beau chercher dans les
rues on ne le voit pas
pourtant il est dans tous les esprits
et qu'il soit considéré comme un homme
ou un mythe seule l'histoire pourra le
condamner ou l'absoudre
[Musique]